et
bonsoir tout le monde
la vie la vie la vie la vie l'univers le
système solaire le soleil la lumière les
planètes l'equilibre l'équilibré force
et les lois naturelles la vie la vie la
terre la terre les sols les sols les
lichens et les mousses l'ancêtre les
mousses l'humus l'humus les plantes les
plantes les arts les arbres la forêt
l'oxygène l'eau la vie la fertilité
l'abondance la luxuriance nous découlant
de ces écosystèmes et pourtant nous
allons en sortir
l'homme va sortir de la forêt il ne va
donc pas à prendre ni comprendre le
coeur même de la nature et certains
zones par esprit d'opposition de refus
ou de dualité vont même aller jusqu'à
profiter à buzet violer tuer et piller
les ressources naturelles et de surcroît
pollué et ce de façon exponentielle
l'espèce humaine est la seule espèce sur
terre qui détruit son environnement
et voilà comment peut-on vivre dans un
monde autant polluée comment peut-on
vivre ensemble en harmonie en étant
autant déconnecté de la nature et de ses
lois naturelles
vivre c'est quoi vivre c'est déjà
respirer boire manger se vêtir et se
loger autant de matières premières que
nous fournit la nature l'homme va
développer aussi des besoins secondaires
il a besoin d'identification personnelle
au sein d'un groupe
l'identification culturelle au sein d'un
groupe de rapports sociaux pour échanger
partager s'éduquer et se cultiver et 2
par son comportement grégaire
l'homme va développer l'agriculture
d'une part il va développer
l'agriculture raisonnée du nôtre
l'agriculture industrielle mécaniques et
chimiques et de notre part l'agriculture
permanente
la permaculture la culture permanente
la paire la culture c'est un concept
basé sur les principes et fonctionnement
même de la nature du génie de la nature
où chaque être vivant à sa place et
assume sa fonction au sein d'un
collectif dans le but de la cohésion de
l'ensemble agir local penser global
le père m'a culteurs s'inspire de cette
intelligence il s'inspire des
organisations mutuelles des mariages et
des symbioses des échanges favorable il
va donc pour ça avoir besoin de temps
pour apprendre et comprendre prendre le
temps comme la nature prend son temps au
contraire des sociétés actuelles qui
vont à une vitesse folle
et son laboratoire ou pour certains sont
m c'est le modèle forestier le modèle
forestier c'est le cycle de la matière
organique du bas vers le haut du haut
vers le bas de l'humus à la
fertilisation de la fertilisation à la
minéralisation à l'assimilation des
nutriments par l'appelant qui remonte
dans la sève créer du bois et de la
feuille est ainsi redonne à la terre le
cycle permanent autofertile et autonome
la clé majeure de cette transformation
c'est la coopération et la collaboration
de l'ensemble des individus pour
recycler cette matière organique en
humus l'humus c'est de l'or c'est de
déclencheur de l'alchimie de la vie des
sols et de sa fertilité
ce premier principe
j'en ai touché les bases quand j'étais
adolescent sans même le savoir par bon
sens
j'ai vu mon père qui essayait de faire
une pelouse devant chez nous elle était
un petit peu rachitique un petit peu
jaunâtre l'été mais j'ai compris le jour
où je les ai vus ramasser des feuilles à
l'automne
je lui dis tu devrais laisser ses
feuilles
parce que les arbres qui font tomber les
feuilles sur la pelouse ça doit avoir un
sens ça offre une couverture divers pour
la végétation et quinze ans plus tard
quand j'ai eu la chance d'avoir mon
premier jardin malheureusement il était
un peu pauvre et un peu rachitique et la
première chose que j'ai faite c'est
d'aller chercher l'authenticité des
choses je suis allé dans la forêt jour
après jour ce haka
rayssac j'ai ramené des feuilles des
branchages du bois pourri des
champignons des petites plantes et de la
microfaune gelé tout simplement est allé
autour des plantes
j'avais tout simplement imiter la nature
et quelques mois plus tard les plants
étaient en très bonne santé
ça se voyait à l'oeil nu le sol vivez la
permaculture
c'est trois principes éthiques
on appelle ça la fleur permaculture elle
trois pétales
le premier principe éthique c'est
prendre soin de la terre on parlait de
bienveillance tout à l'heure c'est
vraiment ça c'est bienveillant envers la
terre prendre soin de l'ensemble de tous
les êtres vivants du plus petit au plus
grand sans discrimination respecter
l'organisation des êtres vivants qui ont
structuré la terre les perliculteurs
concrètement ne va pas labourer la terre
il va apporter beaucoup de matière
organique
il va favoriser la vie et la fertilité
il va faire confiance à la nature et de
ce fait il va moins travailler moins ce
cas c'est le doubs
c'est le deuxième principe éthique
prendre soin des hommes de leur santé
physique et psychique
le troisième principe éthique celle
échanges et le partage
vu que la permaculture est amené à
travailler sans mécanisation ou beaucoup
moins on va travailler ensemble on va
travailler à la main on va donc échanger
toute la journée en travaillant et on va
très heureux de partager les denrées
récoltées
la permaculture concrètement à la base
de l'agriculture
ça se traduit comment quand on fait un
jardin en permaculture
globalement l'idée c'est de rapporter
beaucoup de matières organiques pour
faire vivre le sol le disposés autour de
plantes et ainsi on laisse faire la
nature on va favoriser des associations
bénéfique entre les plantes on va
favoriser la polyculture
contrairement à l'agriculture
industrielle qui elle ne fait que de la
monoculture on va pas mélanger n'importe
comment les choses on va mélanger parce
qu'on sait qu'il ya des plantes
compagnes et des plantes qui sont
défavorables entre elles parmi les camps
les plantes compagnes
on peut dire la carotte et le poireau le
cresson et le radis ou encore la tomate
l'ail et le basilic le chou et la
betterave et dans un rapport rationnelle
et très intelligent que les mayas nous
en a pris c'est le rapport entre le maïs
la ricoh et la courge
c'est un repas végétarien complet et au
niveau du sol dans du micro en très peu
de place on a un repas complet la ricoh
va profiter du tuteur du maïs pour
grimper et la courge par ses grandes
feuilles va offrir un couvert végétal et
donc garder l'humilité au sol le haricot
de plus étant une légumineuse va
assimiler la zot et la retransmettre 6
heures l'homme n'a presque rien fait il
a juste place et les choses là où elle
devrait être il y à aussi
association bénéfique entre plantes et
fleurs
on peut parler d'une là au milieu des
pommes de terre qui par exemple va
éviter aux doryphores devenir la
capucine les oeillets d'inde le cosmos
mais aussi tout ce qui est en herbes
aromatiques de plantes médicinales ou
méditerranéenne qui de plus qu'elles
sont persistantes
pour accueillir acte de la faune pendant
l'hiver elles vont par leur forte odeur
perturber les ravageurs l'idée c'est
d'essayer d'éradiquer les maladies et
les ravageurs sans produits chimiques 0
produits chimiques pour cultiver
sainement
il y a aussi les associations de plantes
avec les animaux par exemple dans un
verger on dispose des poules les poules
au moment où les premiers fruits vont
tomber sont souvent véreuses les poules
vont manger sévère et ainsi arrêter le
cycle du verre ils vont assainir le sol
et deux par leurs fientes
ils vont fertiliser les fruitiers
l'homme n'a rien fait ou presque
il a juste place et les choses au bon
endroit encore une fois il laisse faire
la nature il fait confiance à la nature
de ce fait ils travaillent - la
permaculture dans un sens global
nécessite un très bonne conception un
très bon aménagement de bien penser en
amont les choses pour que le système
devienne durable et pérenne étant
moi-même concepteurs de jardin j'ai
poussé cette idée à 100% de prendre le
temps d'analyser un terrain son
habitation
les besoins du client et les ressources
locales
on va regarder le soleil levant
l'exposition de l'habitation
les zones humides les plantes bio
indicatrices et 2
là on va conceptualiser l'environnement
c'est pour gagner en énergie gagner en
rationalité et gagner en sainteté du
microcosme d'un environnement là où la
permaculture est une idée intéressante
pour l'avenir c'est qu'on peut la
transposer à un modèle de société aux
entreprises aux transports à une ville
pourquoi pas un pays et pourquoi pas du
jardin au jardin planétaire
il y a maintenant une chose que je
voudrais dire c'est que l'homme en
changeant sa nourriture
il change la société et en changeant la
société il change ses valeurs du
producteur au consommateur si le produit
est sain et local
c'est toute une société qui est gagnante
qui est confiante je vous invite donc
tous autant que nous sommes à dépasser
notre condition humaine pour se
reconnecter à la nature faire corps avec
la nature à les faire des balades en
forêt emmener les enfants faire de
longues journées dans la nature
si vous avez la chance d'avoir un petit
bout de terrain cultivé le si vous avez
un petit testera un balcon cultivait le
planter semer au frais à la biodiversité
un recueil pour les papillons pour les
abeilles pour la faune et pour toutes
les plantes et je partirai en dix ans
une citation excusez-moi d'un
monsieur qui a posé des bases
fondamentales dans la permaculture qui
nous vient d'asie et qui épouse donc
naturellement une pensée non dualiste et
non discriminante
c'est monsieur matte abou nouh fukuoka
qui disait travaille dans le sens de la
nature et tout ira bien merci